dritte entlastungspaket ist da die
einzelheiten werden aktuell noch in
einer pressekonferenz der ampel kurz
koalitionäre schwieriges wort
vorgestellt und wir sitzen hier schon
zusammen in der runde um diese
ergebnisse zu beurteilen aber vielleicht
erst mal der eindruck wir haben eine
ganze weile darauf gewartet es sollte
schon bei der kabinettsklausur in
meseberg diese woche konkreter werden
dann schließlich beim
koalitionsausschuss gestern und in den
frühen morgenstunden heute gelangen dann
erst die einigung obwohl die ampel
koalition solche nächtlichen sitzungen
eigentlich vermeiden wollte es war
offensichtlich komplexer und schwieriger
als gedacht aber der kanzler zeigte sich
im anschluss sehr erleichtert hören wir
mal in einen seiner o-töne rein das
dritte leistungspaket dass wir jetzt
geschnürt haben ist von seinem umfang
größer als die ersten beiden zusammen
es hat eine große dimension die wir dort
bewegt haben es geht zum 65 milliarden
euro wie man alles zusammenrechnet es
geht um 95 milliarden euro wenn man die
beiden ersten entlastungs paket
mit einbezieht es ist sehr viel was wir
bewegen es ist notwendig und es soll
dazu beitragen dass die bürgerinnen und
bürgern durch diese situation mit uns
gemeinsam durchgehen können ja olaf
scholz hat das gesagt das ist sehr viel
was da bewegt wird an geld und die frage
ist an der stelle kommt das geld bei den
richtigen menschen an wer soll das alles
bezahlen
und was bedeuten diese beschlüsse im
detail ich freue mich auf die diskussion
heute im presseclub milliarden für
millionen wen entlastet die ampel und
hier in der runde dabei sind michael
brücker er ist chef redakteur bei der
pionier in berlin herzlich willkommen
ich begrüße auch torsten kleditzsch er
ist chefredakteur der neuen presse aus
chemnitz
herzlich willkommen anna lehmann
leiterin des parlamentsbüros der taz in
berlin und ich begrüße dorothea siems
chefökonomen bei der welt wie immer
streamen wir diese sendung auch in den
sozialen netzwerken also wenn sie sich
an der diskussion beteiligen wollen
tatsächlich gibt es schon sehr viele
fragen zum thema dann tun sie das wir
werden das hier in die diskussion
einspeisen wir haben ja gerade frau
siemens einen allgemeinen überblick über
sehr viele maßnahmen bekommen gerade vor
einer stunde erst vielleicht global
betrachtet ist das jetzt aus ihrer sicht
der substanzielle große schritt den die
koalition angekündigt hat oder sind es
vielleicht auch viele einzelmaßnahmen
die sich widersprechen die nicht so gut
zusammenpassen wie ist ihr eindruck also
es ist ein großes paket das zeigt schon
das volumen was genannt wird wobei ja
die zahl der sagt er auch der
bundeskanzler noch nicht ganz fest steht
also 65 milliarden
veranschlagt man jetzt aber mehr als die
hälfte sollen die
energiekonzerne beitragen mit einem
konzept was noch nicht ganz klar ist wie
das funktionieren soll weil wir haben
einen europäischen
energiemarkt und auf europäischer ebene
wird noch verhandelt notfalls würde in
deutschland auch alleine vorangehen hat
scholz gesagt aber ganz klar also wie
viel das bringt kann auch die ampel
nicht sagen aber es ist dort ein
massiver einschnitt geplant sollen da
gewinne abgeschöpft werden und zwar
gerade auch von beispielsweise
produzenten von ökostrom oder atomstrom
oder eben kohlestrom und
die anderen maßnahmen sind tatsächlich
wie auch schon bei den letzten paketen
ein
großer großes paket wo viele
einzelmaßnahmen drin sind die wir uns
gleich noch im einzelnen angucken werden
sie haben es ja gerade schon angedeutet
also ungefähr pi mal daumen die hälfte
dieses paket soll aus dem markt heraus
generiert werden herr brücker wie sehen
sie das ja reden paket wuchtig ist es
würde ich auch sagen wenn man sich die
nackten zahlen anschaut aber formal ist
es vor allem ja auch eine kondition ahl
paket und nicht nur ein konjunkturpaket
weil wenn dann dann ist leider etwas was
ich hier durch dieses papier zieht
europa muss mitmachen damit ist diese
abschöpfung der zusatzgewinne die länder
müssen mitmachen etwa bei der
ticketsteuer und bundesfinanzminister
lindner hat ja gesagt das sind 32
milliarden euro die für den bund nur
wirksam sind dh die 65 milliarden musst
du erstmal durch die mit den ländern
zusammen nehmen und dann kommt die eu
dazu also viele gute sinnvolle maßnahmen
aus meiner sicht aber auch viele bands
und dann vielleicht einfach nur noch zur
einordnung also die 32 milliarden müssen
so sagt lindner aus dem haushalt
genommen werden aus dem bundeshaushalt
und der rest so hatte ich es verstanden
soll aber doch quasi aus dem markt
abgeschöpft werden wie lernt also die
länder sind hier mit dem bodo kannst das
ticket nicht machen das in vorträgen
nicht ohne die länder also sofern viele
von den vorgeschlagenen massnahmen gehen
gar nicht ohne die länder einige von den
entscheidungen sind bundesrats pflichtig
das kommt in zur seite durch relation
zum beispiel genau die kalte progression
und die entlastungen stehen im moment
formal nur auf einem papier okay wir
sind also schon tief in den massnahmen
drin vielleicht erst noch der blick von
ihnen frau lehmann wie bewerten sie das
gesamte paket
also es ist vom umfang her so groß wie
die
haushaltstechnisch gesehen wie die
anderen beiden pakete zusammen es stehen
viele sinnvolle einzelmaßnahmen drin zum
beispiel die anhebung der grenze für
midi jobs auch die wohngeldreform die
angekündigte wohngeldreform ist gut auch
die 300 euro für rentnerinnen sind im
grunde ein guter schritt aber
die gegenfinanzierung ist ungeklärt also
versprochen werden markteingriffe auf
europäischer ebene und die stehen unter
dem vorbehalt einer europäischen
einigung es fehlen dezidiert die
mineralölkonzerne wenn man von über
gewinnsteuern redet wieso werden die
eigentlich ausgenommen die haben so
schätzungsweise 38 milliarden euro nur
in deutschland an über gewinn gemacht
und klimapolitisch ist ein rückschritt
ihr großer blick auf das ganze bevor wir
in die einzelmaßnahmen gehen also wenn
das mit dem strommarkt klappt was die
kollegen kollegen schon angesprochen
haben also durch diese gewinne
abschöpfen zu können und das umzulenken
in die entlastung dann ist das glaub ich
ein großer schritt in sachen
gerechtigkeit weil das ressort
wahrgenommen werden dass man hier
wirklich einem punkt geht wo viele auch
in der öffentlichen debatte gesagt haben
wenn ich das kann ja wohl nicht sein da
verdient mancher momentan wirklich eine
goldene nase dabei wenn das gelingt mit
einer einschränkung wie gesagt wer da
alles sozusagen mit im boot sein muss
dann ist das aus meiner sicht wirklich
eine eine gute botschaft und wir werden
jetzt sehen ob's gelingt bleibe ich beim
stichwort soziale gerechtigkeit frau
sieben es hat schon geatmet
sehen sie das nicht so dass das die
soziale gerechtigkeit bedient als thema
also ich denke bei energie und strom für
die nächsten zwei winter an diesem
winter aber alle sagen ja der nächste
winter wird mindestens so schwierig
werden ist die gerechtigkeitsfrage einer
aber die ganz große frage ist natürlich
gibt es genug energie und strom das ist
keineswegs klar
und was wir jetzt machen das kann man
gerecht finden dass nämlich die die ganz
viel jetzt in der krise
verdienen dass man den was wegnimmt da
sind ja große teil der bevölkerung dafür
die sind es aber immer muss man sagen
ist ja klar war dass es eine kleine
gruppe nur genau die brauchen wir um das
angebot hoch zu halten also wenn wir
jetzt sagen irgendwie es ist unglaublich
dass so ein unternehmen wie auch eon
ganz große gewinne macht mit
erneuerbaren und mit kohleverstromung um
die wir aber betteln das muss man sagen
wir brauchen einen gigantischen ausbau
kohle für die nächsten jahre was co2
also klimapolitisch ziemlich
katastrophal ist aber wir brauchen es
und
erneuerbare daran dass das ganze
programm eigentlich der grünen
politik dass wir da deutlich
beschleunigen und das tun wir mit
investitionen von unternehmen denen wir
jetzt sagen also wenn es richtig gut
läuft dann nehmen wir euch aber was weg
das ist ein ganz ganz schwieriger punkt
den man auf jeden fall im kopf haben
sollte wenn man über gerechtigkeit
gerecht macht das alles sein ist aber
das muss man deswegen ist weg da auch
zwar grundsätzlich dafür aber sagt wir
müssen da aufpassen so einfach mal in
das mag die sein da einzugreifen hat
unter umständen effekte die wir uns
nicht vorstellen können wir sehen das
auf europäischer ebene es gibt
beispielsweise länder die das schon
machen also wie spanien da fließt einmal
subventionierte
strom aus frankreich ab und frankreich
hat großes problem also das ist nicht so
trivial dass man einfach sagt das darf
wird gut verdient und der wird groß
gelitten und dann verteilen wir uns ist
viel für pcs viel komplizierter danke
dass sie dieses feld aufgemacht haben
ich möchte aber noch mal die frage der
sie haben ja durchaus gesagt da steckt
viel soziale gerechtigkeit drin das war
jetzt erst mal der punkt von herrn cage
und sicherlich auch ein punkt der unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer hier
umtreibt frau lehmann deshalb die frage
an sie teile sind gerecht frau siemens
hat das thema aufgemacht aber wenn wir
dann möglicherweise versorgungs
knappheit haben im herbst winter hilft
auch gerechtigkeit nicht mehr richtig
wenn er hat also jedenfalls muss man
diese wirken um zu sagen na toll weil
weil die finanzierung ist auch die art
und weise gemacht von der andere frage
ist noch sind all diese maßnahmen
gerecht also da würde ich sagen sie sind
nicht unbedingt zielgenau aber das
können wir vielleicht später dann auch
noch mal mein sondern ok stichwort
soziale gerechtigkeit ich versuche jetzt
mal bei dem ersten großen kapitel zu
bleiben der strompreis der markteingriff
was wir ja gehört haben ist soll konkret
eigentlich um eine so habe ich
verstanden über gewinnen steuer gehen
bei energieunternehmen nicht beim
mineralölkonzern langen es ja gerade
gesagt sie sind ausgenommen bei
energieunternehmen von denen sie sagen
das sind die die uns eigentlich in
sachen versorgungssicherheit durch den
winter bringen müssen richtig das war
doch jetzt das war einer meiner punkte
der andere punkt ist also das ist man
kann auch nicht einfach also deswegen
ist es keine über gewinnsteuern man sagt
man hat ja ein markt design und man geht
an den
mann geht an die preise innerhalb dieses
marktes insgesamt eine über gewinn
steuer kann man nicht für bestimmte
branchen beschließen das war eine
sondersteuer und da ist das
verfassungsgericht sehr sehr heikel wir
haben dass man mit der atomindustrie
versucht mit einer kern aller
brennelemente steuer die es gekippt
worden weil wenn also im steuersystem
muss geht der gleichheitsgrundsatz also
über gewinnen müsste man definieren was
das ist hier sagt man es gibt einen
markt der ist halt so dass immer der
letzte der reinkommt und
könne schon neue strom
das ist ja es ist nicht ein typischer
markt des wegen der besonderheiten die
wir eine staatlich regulierte sie haben
gerade gesagt es ist eigentlich keine
über gewinn steuer jetzt gebe ich das
mal in die runde frau lehmann haben wir
hier ungefähr das ist ja ein wort was
schon lange in der diskussion kursiert
dass man unternehmen die in dieser krise
besonders viele gewinne machen diese
letztendlich einkassiert weil man sagt
das ist nicht sozial ja ich sehe das so
verstanden ich sehe hier nicht die über
gewinn steuer wie sie von
von von vom netzwerk für
steuergerechtigkeit gefordert worden ist
aber wie sie auch von den grünen ins
spiel gebracht wurde sondern man
beschränkt sich darauf also mannschaft
nicht gewinne ab die tatsächlich jetzt
anfallen sondern man sagt man greift ins
mark design ein und versucht zu
verhindern dass solche gewinne überhaupt
entstehen und so lange sie noch
entstehen schöpfen wir sie ab also die
über gewinnt steuer wie sie angestrebt
wurde wie sie auch ich glaube die
europäische kommission jetzt noch mal
vorgeschlagen hat und wie sie andere
länder zum teil schon einführen oder
beabsichtigen einzuführen
frankreich zum beispiel spanien
griechenland rumänien die wird es in
deutschland nicht geben und das finde
ich problematisch gut ich binde an der
stelle herr brücker sie dürfen sofort
reagieren matthias rehfeld auf twitter
einen der fragt was denken sie ob und
wann die fdp von schuldenbremse und
ablehnung von steuererhöhungen ab rücken
muss um die entlastungen bezahlbar zu
machen diese frage gebe ich ihnen mit
anknüpfend an die diskussion die wir
hier gerade hatten wo soll das geld
herkommt also formal würde ich sagen
eine zufalls gewinn steuer kann man auch
über gewinne steuer oder extragewinn
steuer ich finde diese semantische
debatte ist eigentlich unsinnig aber de
facto ist es eine steuer für
energieunternehmen die sie in einem
gerechtfertigten übrigens 100 jahren
bestehenden markt design erreicht haben
also nun greift schon in diesen markt
ein aber man kann natürlich auch
argumentieren deswegen bin ich durchaus
einen fan davon dass wir durch diesen
exogenen schock eines krieges natürlich
als staat auch eingreifen müssen in
einen nicht funktionierenden markt denn
diese diese gleichbleibenden
produktionskosten für diese energie
unternehmen führen eben zu gewinnen die
so im markt nicht da wären wenn es nicht
diesen krieg gegeben hätte war ein
großer kunde sie vor wie viel sagen also
ja de facto ist das jetzt eine über
gewinn steuer oder zu falls gewünscht
das nicht die richtige debatte es ist
trotzdem ein scheinriese weil dieses
geld kommt nur dann wenn europa mit
macht und ich weiß gar nicht wie lange
das dauern sollen und genau deswegen
kann bundesfinanzminister natürlich
jetzt auch noch sagen 32 milliarden euro
nur wirksam für den bund das ist in
meiner haushaltsplanung möglich er hat
ja inflationsbedingte mehreinnahmen in
diesem jahr ich glaube ihm dass das geht
weil das alles noch gar nicht kommt das
sind alles wunsch maßnahmen die jetzt
hier drin stehen die aufgrund ganz
vieler bedingungen erst entstehen können
und deswegen ist es im moment glaube ich
tatsächlich möglich die schuldenbremse
einzuhalten mit diesen maßnahmen weil
weil sie einfach konditionell sind und
weil sie einfach so viele wenns und dann
beinhalten damit sie überhaupt wirksam
werden herr brücke eine nachfrage dazu
ich habe urlaub ist eben auch genau
zugehört und ich habe mir notiert wir
werden die marktordnung ändern dass es
solche zufalls gewinne das war jetzt der
der begriff derbe verwendet wurde nicht
mehr gibt die eu arbeitet daran entweder
wir schaffen es gemeinsam oder wir
machen es auf nationaler ebene und das
halt dafür hoch problematisch meint herr
scholz damit nahezu den alleingang einen
nationalen alleingang in einem
europäischen strom design ist ein
völliger irrweg denn dann kaufen uns die
italiener die franzosen im egal welcher
energieversorger aus den anderen ländern
übrigens schon geschehen in spanien und
italien kaufen dann im energiemarkt die
bei uns günstig subventionierten preise
für energie kaufen sie uns weg und
insofern kannst du keinen nationalen
alleingang mache in einem europäischen
energiemarkt ich halte das für
hochproblematisch entweder es gibt eine
europäische lösung oder es herrscht
chaos diese diese zahlen kann man nicht
sinnvoll einplanen im haushalt bei einer
nationalen energiestrategie europäische
player dann bei uns die günstigen in die
winzige energie einkaufen das hat
spanien und italien gerade erlebt und
hat damit bruchlandung alle und wir
könnten lücken haben und wir könnten
versorgungssicherheit nicht darin viele
deutsche system
und ich finde auch als spekulant also
ich meine die öko strom herstellen das
war ein politisches ziel übrigens der
markt das nicht seit 100 jahren weil
diese dieser vorrang für grünen strom
der ist neu den gibt es seit 20 jahren
also das ist ja schon auch ein eingriff
gewesen zu sagen die gehen immer vor das
hat ja auch die kalkulation der anderen
verändert deswegen kommen ja zum
beispiel im moment auch die kohle
weil es eben diese hürden gibt und wir
sollten aufpassen dass wir nicht in
einer situation rein rat geraten die
nämlich wirklich viel viel dramatischer
dann ist wenn es wenn es diese
knappheiten gibt in spitzenzeiten und
das wird der winter sein aber wir haben
jetzt genau erklären ich wollte sie
gerade mit rein holen weil wir jetzt uns
ein bisschen über die finanzierung hier
schon ausgetauscht haben und die
probleme die brücker und frau sie muster
sehen herr klee durchkomme zur sozialen
gerechtigkeit zurück also es ist ja
mittel zum zweck so zu sagen man geht ja
diesen weg um genau die entlastung zu
schaffen die für die bürgerinnen und
bürger in ostdeutschland besonders
wichtig ist wie blicken sind darauf also
mein trick jahres hier überhaupt nichts
mehr also bald bei dem ganzen thema das
ist unwahrscheinlich komplex oder hat
sich auch sonst nicht markteingriffen
sehr zurückgehalten es gab ja noch ganz
andere vorschläge die auf dem tisch
lagen insofern ich glaube nur dass bei
dem thema versorgungssicherheit und
darauf nochmal zu antworten in diesem
winter nicht entscheidend sein wird was
die deutschen industrieunternehmen
energieunternehmen noch leisten können
weil dafür ist einfach die zeit viel zu
kurz bis zu diesem winter sondern das
hängt in moskau also das wird eindeutig
darüber entscheiden wie es in diesem
winter aussieht so zu sagen inwieweit
dieser gashahn aufgedreht und inwieweit
wir uns vielleicht in sachen atom
durchringen können die die kraftwerke
weiterlaufen zu lassen das ist glaube
ich wichtig aber ist es sie haben aus
meiner sicht recht man muss sehen wie
das auch in der wirtschaft rein wirkt
die man natürlich braucht um langfristig
diese energiewende hin zu kriegen man
muss auf der anderen seite aber auch
aufpassen dass man die leute bei der
stange erhält also wenn man so eine
veränderung und change hinkriegen will
dann klappt das am ende nur wenn man den
großteil der bevölkerung dabei hat und
wir müssen das gefühl haben dass ihre
interessen eher wahrgenommen werden und
im osten ist es halt ein bisschen
besondere immer noch mal ein besonders
sensibel weil die anzahl derjenigen die
hässlichkeiten gewissen prekären
verhältnissen befinden das trifft genau
so auf die unternehmen zu größer ist und
vielleicht an der stelle ist es ganz gut
wir hatten am donnerstag auch einen
aktuellen ard deutschlandtrend bei uns
im programm der sich genau mit dieser
frage befasst hat also der blick also
wir sie halten ja an den sanktionen
gegenüber russland fest aktuell zu
beginn des krieges im märz gefragt und
jetzt wieder gefragt finden sie das
richtig auch wenn dadurch die preise
steigen auch wenn dadurch möglicherweise
die versorgungssicherheit in gefahr ist
und wenn unternehmen leiden vielleicht
können wir gerade mal auf die grafik
schauen die wir dafür vorbereitet haben
es gibt nämlich deutliche unterschiede
bei der haltung also auch wenn
energiepreise und lebenshaltungskosten
steigen gesamt 53 prozent sagen ja das
muss sein 41 sind dagegen aber wenn man
auf west und ost schaut sieht man die
mehrheiten sind im westen deutlich bei
ja wir sind immer noch für die
sanktionen gegen russland und im osten
ist die mehrheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger in den östlichen bundesländern
sagt nein dann müssen wir die sanktionen
auf den prüfstand stellen von daher
bleibe ich auch so bei dem thema der
sozialen gerechtigkeit was sie an der
stelle ja noch mal konkret angesprochen
haben jetzt haben sie aber auch den
brückenschlag weil alles hängt mit allem
zusammen zu den unternehmen gemacht
wir haben ja festgestellt dass in den
ersten beiden entlastungspaket
der mittelstand und die kleineren
betriebe die jetzt möglicherweise auch
unter den sehr sehr großen energiekosten
zu leiden haben noch nicht richtig
berücksichtigt worden sind wenn sie
jetzt konkret darauf schauen also aus
dem was wir bislang wissen wie
beurteilen sie das was das dritte
entlastungspaket der vorsicht also ich
glaube da kommt noch sehr stark auf das
auf die details an was sind
energieintensive unternehmen ist das
auch eine gießerei ich hoffe ja also
gerade zum autozulieferung bereich wäre
das zum beispiel für unsere region ganz
wichtiger bereich also das müsste das
muss noch definiert wenn das kann man
auch nicht verlangen dass das heute klar
ist muss man auch so deutlich sagen aus
meiner sicht und auf der anderen seite
steht auch drin dass man sozusagen
zukunftsfähige firmen nicht in der
situation kommen lassen will dass sie
aufgrund dieser energiekrise ihre
zukunft verlieren wie man das dann
praktisch ausgestalten will weiß ich
auch noch nicht das müsste man
sicherlich auch definieren also da was
aus meiner sicht weniger konkret als bei
der entlastung der bürgerinnen bürger
sie haben gerade gesagt
das hätte man vorbereitet das finde ich
ist der hauptpunkt so konkret sie werden
bei studierenden bei rentnern bei
wohngeldempfängern mit grund die zahlen
so unkonkret werden sie bei den
unternehmenshilfen und die wahrheit ist
dass wir eine schleichende
deindustrialisierung ja längst haben in
diesem land und deswegen hätte ich mir
gewünscht dass es nicht wieder im
kfw-sonderprogramm ich brauche keinen
kredit wenn ich kein cash flow habe wenn
ich vor der insolvenz stehe brauche ich
kein kfw-kredit den ich mühsam
beantragen sondern ich brauche echte
entlastung bei den industrie
strompreisen vielleicht auch bei unseren
umsatz und mehrwertsteuer und da ist aus
meiner sicht gar nichts drin und das
finde ich eigentlich schade weil der
mittelstand soll ja angeblich derjenige
sein mit dem wir aus der krise kommen
damit wir sollen ja immer aus der krise
wachsen habe ich gelernt den letzten
wochen an jedem sonntag statement und
montags stehen dann sehr viele tolle
entlastung für viele gute wichtige
gruppen drin aber für den mittelstand
und die unter den inhabergeführten
unternehmen lese ich hier nichts das ist
nicht ganz richtig ganz kurze es gibt
ja der ist ja auch ganz klein oder ein
nebensatz eigentlich gewesen dass dieser
vor
grundtarif sozusagen im strom dass das
auch für für kleine und mittlere
betriebe gilt ja nur dann werden die
gelder kommen der hält ja nur dann wenn
die gassen gelder wenden wenn das gehalt
erlaubt wird aber dass man daneben sagt
wir subventionieren da noch herunter
nur wenn jetzt nochmals gewinn steuer
kommt erzählt ja finanziert auch die
preise als gewünscht und so könnte es
wieder wenn dann aber
ich wollte nur sagen also ansonsten bin
ich ganz bei ihnen also ich finde ein
programm war so groß ist und letztlich
lässt sich das auch schon für die
letzten wahlen sagen wir geben
unglaublich viel geld aus für dinge die
die jetzt nicht unbedingt nötig sind
sagen wir es mal so zu sagen zielgenau
ist dass alle rentner zu entlasten sehe
ich nicht so ich sehe er rentner es gibt
natürlich eine gruppe der geht es nicht
gut das ist jetzt nicht erst in der
krise aber jetzt natürlich besonders
aber es gibt natürlich rentner denen es
durchaus so geht wie auch im
arbeitnehmer bereich
personen die keinen also die das wuppen
können und genauso ist es mit dem mit
dem verlängerten 9 euro ticket das seien
61 euro ticket wird das sind gelder die
sind das sind annehmlichkeiten jeder
finanziert sind und damit ich ihnen
widersprechen nicht nicht dinge wir
müssen darüber reden wie stabilisieren
wir eine wirtschaft mit einem wo das
geschäftsmodell nicht mehr trägt das ist
keine frage von 12 jahren
ihr müsst sie muss sich umstrukturieren
ich hätte mir steuer
steuerliche anreize gewünscht für
unternehmen sich auf diese zukunft
besser vorbereiten zu können das gibt es
nicht das ist überhaupt nicht vorgesehen
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass es stärker
in richtung zukunft geht wir werden
keine zwei jahre krise haben und dann
ist alles vorbei wir werden dauerhaft
viel viel höhere energiekosten haben und
wir hatten die höchsten in europa und
fast der welt also das ist ein problem
sonst wird es hier auch mit der
wirtschaft das wird alles an kosten
kommen es gibt jetzt die ersten
stahlwerke die gesagt haben wir
produzieren nicht mehr in deutschland
hiervon machen nur eine große arbeit das
sind finanzen diesem tier überhaupt
nicht
darauf reagieren sie gerade das wort an
nämlich geleiten gedacht da muss ich
ihnen ja da möchte ich ihnen der
sprechen also das ist das nur ein euro
ticket das war keine annehmlichkeiten
mobilität das halte ich für ein
grundrecht und das hat viele viele
menschen entlastet ganz konkret
entlastet und wenn man sich die folgen
wenn man sich aber vor allen dingen auch
geringverdiener denn wer wer mit bus und
bahn und wenn ich mir wenn ich mir
angucke die verbraucherpreise sind im
juli in allen bereichen gestiegen außer
im bereich bus und bahn für viele
menschen war es eine sehr konkrete
entlassen übrigens auch für die von
ihnen zitierten rentner und rentnerinnen
und erklärt ich in einem buch möchte ich
ihnen auch widersprechen wenn sie sagen
ob wir gut durch den winter kommen das
hängt davon ab ob wir den weiterbetrieb
der verbliebenen atommeiler um was weiß
ich drei monate sechs monate was auch
immer sich ein nein wäre wir haben ja
wir haben ja vor allen dingen dame
problemen kein strom problem wir haben
auch ohne strümpfe und
atomstrom liefern
wer solche strommenge aber das ist das
ist eine puk ideologische
aber dass mittelfristig und langfristig
entscheidend es ist der ausbau der
erneuerbaren damit man eben wegkommt von
gas und schon und und kohle auch von
kohle und von öl und das fraktion und
unternimmt man jetzt diesen unternehmen
da da da gebe ich ihnen recht dass das
ist dass diese die die eingriffe allein
in den strommarkt und diese umgekehrt
eeg-umlage halte ich auch für schwierig
wie so macht man nicht eine eine über
gewinnsteuern wo man sagt man die christ
bestimmte kriterien fest zb eben dass es
eine krise gibt dass es das gewinne
anfallen die ja als windfall profit als
zufalls gewinne einfallen und guckt sich
auch an wie ist denn das design der
unternehmen in diesem markt beispiel
mineralölkonzerne da sind oligopole
entstanden die können einfach auf die
können einfach den preis bestimmen die
nachfrage ist ja nicht gestiegen die
nachfrage ist genau gleich und dann
kommt man auch auf die energiekonzerne
aber dann kommt man natürlich auch auf
die mineral wir sind aus gründen wieder
bei den energiepreisen ich möchte einmal
kurz innehalten also die zugewinns
zufalls steuer oder über gewinn steuer
wie wir es jetzt nennen hatten wir
gerade schon an getextet sie haben jetzt
die umgekehrte eeg-umlage genannt also
das war auch teil der pressekonferenz wo
es hieß das soll also anders als von den
leuten genommen sollen die leute
entlastung bekommen das ist mit
umgekehrter eeg-umlage gemeint nicht
dass wir hier unsere zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer verlieren und beim thema
um kraftwerke haben wir ein strom oder
ein gas problem hat sich hier natürlich
überall widerstand genetisch sie bitte
ja also eigentlich wollte ich ihn gerade
zustimmen was die was das neue europa
anbelangt
völlig bei ihnen das hat nicht nur etwas
mit gerechtigkeit zu tun sondern das ist
so ein sehr praktisches beispiel gewesen
wo man gelernt hat wie durch eine
einfache lösung menschen in eine andere
mobilität gebracht werden können nicht
dass sie eine andere mobilität haben
sondern weil das aus meiner sicht zu dem
thema
versorgungssicherheit beiträgt wir
werden es vermutlich nicht schaffen
durch den ausbau der erneuerbaren und
auch der anderen nur schwer ohne
einsparung sozusagen die
versorgungssicherheit herzustellen also
müssen wir auf der anderen seite zu
minder verbrauch an energie kommen und
das kann man glaube ich durch das ticket
das wird nicht alle probleme lösen aber
das kann dazu beitragen und es ist etwas
was jeder versteht also nicht nur das es
preiswert ist sondern ich kann es
überall nutzen also ich hätte heute in
chemnitz einsteigen und hier in köln
wieder das letzte stück von mir aus mit
der s-bahn noch fahren können mit einem
mit einem tigers wäre einfach einfach
bei der atomindustrie den satz noch ich
bin auch kein verfechter der
atomindustrie aber ich fände es in der
jetzigen situation einfach leichtfertig
zu sagen wir verzichten auf die drei
blöcke die alle kraftwerke die dann noch
laufen 56 prozent des stromverbrauchs
bedarf in deutschland decken die ab das
versteht momentan weniger und man
verspielt sich glaube ich eher die die
grundsätzliche bereitschaft in
deutschland für die energiewende und für
den ausstieg aus der atomkraft wenn man
jetzt aus meiner sicht eher
kurzsichtigen ich würde auch er seinen
ideologischen gründen sagt wir lassen
wir schalten sie ab egal was passiert
und hab ich ganz kurz er weil das ist ja
heute nicht beschlossen worden gestresst
ich werde genau gespielt diesmal soll
nicht so weil man soll bloß nicht so tun
als ob vom weiterbetrieb dieser drei
meiler unsere energieversorgung in
deutschland aber vielleicht auch also
wir haben nicht so viel reden sondern
wir reden wochen über einen rekord
strompreis an rekord in toulouse geht
das über das steht aber gar nicht in den
papieren moment aber wenn sie es
ansprechen muss man
hat alles
den namen hans hat
erwähnt naja es war immerhin die pkk
zudem beschloss also es war nicht
irgendein täglich einrichtung ist schon
so muss ja im harburger einsatz und der
sozialen komponente hat es das angebot
an energie in diesem land zu erhöhen
egal woher es kommt ob es aus franke
kommt oder atomkraftwerke muss
diskutiert werden dürfen wir dadurch
sinkt der strompreis der natürlich teil
der großen belastung gerade ist gegen
astoria sinnlos diskutiert werden völlig
richtig die argumente bedeutet worden
wir haben aber heute nicht in der
pressekonferenz die er wird der
stresstest kommt wir werden schauen wie
viele akw es möglicherweise entweder mit
dem strick betrieb oder mit neuen
brennelementen das ist ja in der
diskussion ist aber heute nicht
entschieden ich möchte auf das 9 euro
ticket zurückkommen weil vielleicht
unseren bei unserem publikum gar nicht
klar ist was eigentlich beschlossen
wurde das möchte ich hier kurz mal
vortragen also es wird ein
nachfolgemodell für das 9 euro ticket
befürwortet dafür stellt der bund 1,5
milliarden euro zusätzlich zur verfügung
die länder müssen mindestens den
gleichen beitrag zur verfügung stellen
das ist wieder dieses wenn dann was ja
brücke im brücker gerade schon an
getextet hat und das ticket soll dann
zwischen 49 und 69 euro pro monat kosten
also es geht nicht mehr um neun euro
ticket sondern um ein reduziertes ticket
mit dem man den ganzen pnv in
deutschland nutzen könnte ist das im
sinne der sozialen gerechtigkeit erklärt
ich habe sie ja gerade schon gesagt da
wollten sie frau lehmann zustimmen das
finden sie gut
wie stehen sie zum nachfolgermodell herr
brücke hat genickt dann nehme ich ihnen
mal wenn er zufrieden ist ja ich glaube
weil es jetzt kritischer insofern ich
bin tatsächlich ein großer anhänger
eines neuen euro ticket vor allem weil
sie die vereinfachung angesprochen haben
die digitalisierung auch der zwang dass
diese länder verkehrsminister sich
endlich mal einigen das ist ein unding
ist das zwischen zwei verkehrsverbünden
man irgendwelche neuen ticket ziehen
muss das aber der verein fans gerade die
wahrheit ist aber auch dass eine familie
oder eine alleinerziehende mutter im
oldenburger land davon nichts hat wenn
der bus einmal im monat einmal im monat
zwar schon einmal in der stunde kommt
also man muss auch mal ein bisschen für
uns ist das wunderbar in berlin-mitte
kann ich die s-bahn jetzt nutzen für 39
49 vielleicht werden weil sie nicht aber
es ist kein große entlastung für die
arbeitende mitte die in deutschland bis
zu 80 prozent im ländlichen raum wohnt
und gar kein angebot an öpnv hat und
wenn ein katastrophales das muss man
zumindest mitdiskutieren also ich bin es
gibt untersuchungen die zeigen
autoverkehr ist nicht reduziert worden
stadt hat mehr produktion profitiert als
das land was ich will mobilität geht da
einen ganz schwierigen das sind aber die
uns sind ja ist ja also weil sie sagen
autoverkehr ist nicht reduziert worden
das sind die erkenntnisse aus dem ersten
monat wir sind ja noch dabei datensätze
zu erfahren ist die erfolgreichen
überlagere nur wenn man die chaos tage
bei der bahn in den letzten drei monaten
hört dann würde ich sagen wenn es um
mobilität geht würde ich das geld
investieren und man kann die mobilität
ich sehe das auch als ein grundrechte im
unteren bereich es ist auch teil von
grundsicherung ist dort veranschlagt wir
haben die möglichkeit auch immer in den
kommunen in berlin wird das ja schon
lange gemacht
solche tickets dann zu vergünstigen
extrem zu vergünstigen bis hin zu
kostenlos bei uns sind also das ist
alles machbar nur allen ich meine bei
diesem ticket sind alle dabei was soll
das also was sollen wir gut verdienen
die mobilität die dann zusätzlich
vielleicht eben weil man auch gerne mal
am wochenende dann die regionalbahn
nutzbar so billig ist das ist doch kein
kein ziel was man machen muss darum
gehen am letzten prioritäten dass man am
wochenende endet auch die regionalbahnen
nutzen anstatt das auto ist hat es hat
ja zwei komponenten dass das neun euro
ticket ist es nachher jetzt mal so dass
eine war dass man den umstieg auf
öffentliche verkehrsmittel fördert und
ich bin mir sicher die zahlen werden
auch ergeben dass ein teil derer die das
neue europa genutzt haben ich glaube
zehn prozent waren sie hatten dazu eine
umfrage gemacht
statt auf das auto auf den öpnv
umgestiegen sind und es ist aber auch
eine entlastung und zwar für leute die
häufig den öpnv nutzen und sich sonst
monatskarten kaufen müssen ich möchte
noch mal auf die soziale komponente
kommen weil sie ja danach gefragt haben
ist das ganze paket sozial gerecht ich
finde es problematisch dass das dass die
verlängerung oder der nachfolger das
neun euro tickets zu wolkig wir wollen
das tun ein bisschen raus genommen wurde
aus dem ganzen un man sich nicht darauf
geeinigt hat dass man es tatsächlich zu
einem bestimmten datum einführt ich
finde auch problematisch dass viele der
angesprochenen entlastung erst ab erst
eingreifen die verteuerung kommen aber
tatsächlich ja ab oktober auf uns zu
also wenn man an die wohngeldreform
denkt ab januar soll das gelten
kindergelderhöhung die die rentner
profitieren jetzt von ihren
direktzahlung auch die entlastung für
minijobs und
das bürgergeld wurde ja auch
angesprochen da wird da wird jetzt die
inflation die angenommene inflation rein
gerechnet das ist gut aber an der
berechnungsmethode ändert sich eben
nicht und das ist schlecht weil
man viele wissen das nicht aber die
bezieher von arbeitslosengeld 2 der
staat erstattet die kosten für
unterkunft und heizung aber er erstattet
eben nicht die kosten für den strom das
müssen die leute selber tragen und
bestimmte posten sind ganze ausgerechnet
zum beispiel restaurantbesuche darunter
fällt auch dass man was sich an der
eisdiele warten man es kauft und so
weiter also daran ändert sich nichts
also das heißt es gibt für diese
menschen inflationsbedingten besseren
ausgleich aber er hält das problem der
armut wird sich dadurch damit nicht ein
problem an ich wollte gerade vom
nachfolger des neuen euro tickets auf
die direktzahlungen kommen die jetzt
tatsächlich beschlossen worden sind sie
haben gerade schon gesagt das bürgergeld
rund 500 euro angehoben mit blick auf
die kommende inflation das wurde auch
gesagt das sei etwas neues das man auf
die steigende inflation guckt wir haben
zahlungen an rentnerinnen und rentner
einmalzahlung in höhe von 300 euro an
studierende in höhe von 200 euro also
das ist jetzt so was die einzel
individual- maßnahmen angeht und
vielleicht in diesem zusammenhang franz
huber der auf twitter fragt was ist
eigentlich mit den kleinen
selbstständigen die unter dem
grundfreibetrag verdienen werden die
wieder vergessen herr brücke ja die
selbstständige tauchen nicht auf punkt
das ist übrigens bei den ersten beiden
entlastungs paketen auch schon der fall
gewesen und deswegen können wir wieder
gerne und zu recht auch über alle
rentnerinnen männer reden die jetzt mit
sechs milliarden euro übrigens im jahr
entlastet werden durch diese
einmalzahlung wunderbar konkret auch bei
den studierenden wohngeld sehr konkret
wobei ich ihnen widersprechen muss ist
wird es wird gar nicht kommen weil er so
einfach ist es nicht die bundesregierung
kann nicht einfach zahlen dar ein
schreiben und sagen habe ersten ersten
machen wir das sie hatten die kann den
arbeitgebern nicht sagen welche
steuerfreie leistung sie als
einmalzahlung ihre beschäftigten aus
britz hat sie kann den ländern nicht
vorschreiben dass sie in ihrer
kernkompetenz pnv das ticket zum ersten
ersten umsetzungen und übrigens auch das
wohngeld wird definitiv das bürgergeld
nicht am ersten erster kommt die
bundesagentur für arbeit kann ich in der
lage ist diesen umstellungsprozess zu
machen manches geht eben nicht so
schnell aber es stimmt trotzdem aus
meiner sicht die selbstständigen wie so
oft auch der kleine inhabergeführte
mittelstand wird vergessen erklärt wie
stehen sie dazu was der brücker
geradeaus gefüttert dass das
möglicherweise aus pragmatischen gründen
einfach in der ausführung zum ersten
januar gar nicht möglich ist wir haben
das kann ich nur weil man muss beim
neuen euro ticket sogar darauf hinweisen
dass der bund den letzten wochen also
zumindest meiner beobachtung aus der
ferne nach um die länder durchaus
geworben hat das ding vorzubereiten und
er der widerstand aus den ländern kamen
die sind so alle im prinzip dafür aber
beim geld halten sich wie immer dann
zurück und dass das jetzt in der kürze
der zeit geschafft werden soll es wäre
schön aber zweifel sender durchaus
angebracht ich würde mal sagen was aus
sozialer gerechtigkeit würde ich die
wohngeld ausweitung als den besten punkt
sehen dass auch künftig die heizkosten
eine größere rolle spielen sondern auch
nochmal klimakomponente war ja künftig
auch das verschiebt man jetzt dabei eben
die die co2 steuer dann noch obendrauf
kommt also das ist ein punkt wo man
wirklich sagen dass das verstehe ich
unter zielgenau weil das sind leute die
haben echtes problem die es ist
nachgewiesen man hat die schon auch dann
in der kartei dh die sind das ist aber
eine vollkommen andere gruppe die über
schneidet sich teilweise mit
arbeitnehmern teilweise mit studenten
teilweise mit rentnern aber eben immer
nur teilweise während diese anderen
gruppen auch studenten ich meine wir
wissen studenten kommen überwiegend aus
eltern sagen mit guten einkommen ich
finde das ist nicht notwendig dass sie
alle jetzt als arm dargestellt natürlich
haben deren sind deren einkommen sind
unterdurchschnittliche weil eben
studenten überall auf der welt immer
erstmal aus mit kleinem geld aber die
haben die aussicht natürlich auch
deutlich überdurchschnittliche
einkommen später ich finde nicht dass
die eine gruppe sind die die sozial
schwach ist und deswegen ist es so ich
sehe das bei renten und das hatten wir
schon in dieser art von von breiten
streuung soll dann immer auch dienen das
ist populär ist übrigens genauso wie das
neue euro ticket ebenso populär war weil
natürlich alle sich freuen irgendetwas
zu kriegen aber die meckern trotzdem
werden sie dann wieder an der kasse
stehen und zwar zu recht weil da hilft
es ihnen dann eben gehandelt ich würde
hier einen harten kampf machen wollen
was die einzelmaßnahmen angeht weil wir
sind schon in dem schlussspurt zum ende
unserer sendung ich möchte aber einmal
in der schlussrunde noch drauf schauen
wie hat denn aus ihrer sicht die ampel
regierung bislang geliefert oder
geleistet ich habe ja schon anmoderiert
ist hat länger gedauert als eigentlich
geplant aber wir haben ja auch darüber
geredet da sind natürlich
unterschiedliche stimmen am werk bei den
ampelkoalition ehren frau lehmann wie
finden sie bis hierhin die performance
wie man so schön sagt unsere regierung
naja die ampel regierung hat natürlich
er agiert als reagiert der
koalitionsvertrag wurde unter anderen
voraussetzungen geschlossen sie mein
reagiert als agiert habe ich reagiert
als agiert ich genau also sie hat auf
krisen auf die krisen die da kam
reagiert dabei sind auch fehler passiert
wie zum beispiel die gasanlage die hier
in papierform so auch nicht erwähnt wird
und deren rücknahme auch also die wird
nicht zurückgenommen die wird höchstens
korrigiert und ich hätte mir tatsächlich
aber auch von diesen dritten
entlastungspaket selbst wenn man im
modus der krisen regierung agiert agiert
tatsächlich auch mehr schutz bei
erwartet man hat sich ja als
fortschritts regierung aufgestellt und
immer nur auf dem kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenner sich zu bewegen das war
eigentlich das was man ich vermeiden
wollte erklärte ich hätte mir zum einen
mehr emotionalität in der ansprache
gewünscht da kann olaf scholz nicht über
seinen schatten springen offensichtlich
aber das ist einfach notwendig um die
menschen auch zu erreichen und ich hätte
mir zum zweiten gewünscht dass man
früher erklärt was heute mit anklagen
was auch vor 7 setzt klar gesagt hat
dass nur zuerst sozusagen bei den
ursachen geschaut ob man eine
versorgungssicherheit hat bevor man die
anderen schritte darauf aufbaut ja ich
würde auch sagen also ich hätte mir mehr
zukunfts gewandtheit auch in der krise
weil das ist das warum auch die
bevölkerung langsam unsicher wird was
die kompetenzen angeht in dieser
regierung dass man das gefühl hat die
haben kein kompass wir müssen gucken wo
steuert unsere wirtschaft hin das geld
raus zu hauen ist einfach das kann alle
anderen können alle anderen regierungen
in europa übrigens auch unser geld wird
bis auf die art und weise irgendwann
nichts mehr wert sein also das ist nicht
das konzept worauf es ankommt eigentlich
sondern es kommt darauf an zu wissen da
ist die zukunft und die muss grüner sein
das wissen wir die muss solide sein
sonst ist das alles nicht gewährt und
die muss wirtschaftlich wir müssen
technisch in die vorderhand kommen und
dafür hätte es irgendwelche ansätze
gebrauch davon ist nichts zu sehen der
brücker gute politik ist im idealfall
vorausschauend transparent
nachvollziehbar und unaufgeregt all das
war aus meiner sicht die ampel den
letzten monaten nicht so fern ist so
viel vertrauen verspielt worden der in
diese in diesem land und das ist schade
weil wir kommen wahrscheinlich wirklich
gerade in eine existentielle
wirtschaftskrise für den standort
deutschland und da glaube ich bräuchte
man ein bisschen mehr konsistenz also
ein durchaus gemischtes bild hier wenn
man auf die arbeit der ampel regierung
schaut danke bis hierhin für die sehr
sehr spannende und engagierte diskussion
es geht jetzt hier weiter im ersten mit
dem europamagazin was ich auch mit dem
thema energie befasst unter anderem ob
spanien das neue vorbild für die eu
werden könnte oder was es mit dem
energie notstand in frankreich auf sich
hat wenn sie aber bei dieser diskussion
bleiben wollen gibt's presseclub
nachgefragt auf phoenix auf wdr 5 und
natürlich im livestream auf den sozialen
plattformen danke und ein schönen
sonntag noch
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder mit mit
presseclub nachgefragt bei phoenix auf
wdr 5 und in den sozialen medien im live
stream ich freue mich auf weitere
engagierte argumente in dieser runde zum
thema milliarden für millionen wen
entlastet die ampel jetzt haben unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer das wort
und ich möchte als erstes zu eitel
wieder nach fulda gehen hallo guten tag
und ihre frage bitte an die runde und
einmal kompliment zu ihrer weitestgehend
sehr bitte zur sendung und konstruktiv
kritischen sendung ich habe eine
zentrale frage und zwar an herrn brücke
der form des heute als weitgehend
aktionismus vorgestellten paket ist nach
dem gießkannenprinzip wie das alles
gegenfinanziert werden soll ob er da im
grunde eine idee danke danke für ihre
frage herr brücke haben sie eine idee
die die gretchenfrage den würde ich
gerne weiter leiten ein
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
aber ich glaube wie gesagt dass wir hier
über zahlen reden gerade die so nicht
etat wirksam für den bundeshaushalt
werden und deswegen kann christian
lindner der einen sehr selbstbewussten
auftritt gegeben hatte wahrscheinlich
auch davon sprechen dass es eben keine
größeren probleme in seinem haushalt
gibt es gibt unglaubliche
steuermehreinnahmen durch die inflation
das ist logisch und das sind milliarden
die wir jetzt in den nächsten wochen
wahrscheinlich dann auch höheren werden
und ein großteil dieser entlastung wird
eigentlich durch uns selbst finanziert
nämlich durch die inflations bedingten
steuermehreinnahmen und alles andere was
nächstes jahr kommen werden wir sehen ob
er dann doch noch mal an die schulden
gehen muss oder nicht ich weiß es nicht
herr brücke zumindest in teilen ratlos
weil das thema einfach so komplex ist
das gibt's ja auch nicht alle tage wir
gehen zu antje klingt nach bargteheide
hallo und was wollen sie von der runde
wissen
ja ich wollte daten ich weiß nicht ob
ich jetzt plant sie sind dran frauke
spitze ja also ich wollte sagen ganz
kurz wenn geldknappheit und das ist auch
wirklich war in dieser zeit warum geht
man nicht an die barreserven
deutschland ist so viel ich weiß dass
drittreichste land auf der welt an
goldreserven und ich habe einmal gefragt
in dieser sendung das warum man nicht an
die sache herangeht wenn man in not ist
aber ich würde sagen wir sind in
tiefster not warum gehen wenn ich an
unsere goldreserven sagt war meine frage
danke frau klingt wir sind in größter
not frau siemens wollen sie darauf
antworten also an die goldreserven zu
gehen ist aus vielen gründen nicht nicht
sehr zielführend das eine ist man kann
es einmal machen dann sind sie weg es
gibt halt
zentralbank systemen immer die die
aufgabe auch ein teil in reserven zu
halten in anderen währungen aber eben
auch in gold gold ist zum im moment auch
gar nicht auf seien einem sehr hohen
preis man würde es also auch letztlich
verschleudern aber das ist eigentlich
ein staat der die möglichkeit hat sich
zu finanzieren sei es über steuern wir
sind ja nicht im nach dem krieg jetzt
wir haben steuermittel hier haben die
möglichkeit schulden aufzunehmen für
kurzfristige
überbrückung oder auch für investitionen
da ist gold kein gutes instrument das
ist er so in der vergangenheit gewesen
als das geld an gold gekoppelt war aber
das ist schon seit den 70er jahren nicht
mehr der fall
danke wir wollen als nächstes gabriele
laibach aus essen zu wort kommen lassen
hallo und ihre frage bitte guten tag in
die runde meine frage richtig auch an
alle in die runde und an alle bürger und
alle
wirtschaftsunternehmen in deutschland
und europa könnte man dazu aufrufen
klammer auf verursacherprinzip die
aktien und fonds der ölmultis
exemplarisch zu verkaufen so lange bis
man das preisniveau der kriegsgewinnler
schafft verletzt
wir scheinen gerade sehr ohnmächtig aber
das finde ich ein sehr
probates mittel um diese konzerne die ja
für die preistreiberei und unsere großen
probleme gerade verantwortlich sind zu
disziplinieren
frage in die runde wer auch jeder von
ihnen bereit so man denn über aktien
oder fonds verfügt am montag zur
hausbank zu gehen um
die ihr da mal nachzufragen von laibach
ich habe es verstanden es geht darum die
aktien von öl
konzernen abzustoßen am montag am besten
noch wenn man solche hat
frau lehmann ich besitze weder weder
aktien noch france aber es gibt ein
besseres mittel als dass man unternehmen
zwingt beziehungsweise die unternehmen
besitzen ja offen ich diese aktion und
funktionen des besitzers shareholder man
könnte einfach erfassen wer wieviele wer
wie viel vermögen besitzt darunter auch
aktien aber auch immobilien
geldwerte alles und dann führt man eine
vermögenssteuer ein oder eine
vermögensabgabe was auch immer es gibt
ja ein konzept unter anderem von der
parlamentarischen linken der spd für
eine einmalige vermögensabgabe
das würde einen sehr kleinen aber sehr
reichen teil der bevölkerung treffen
ungefähr 0,4 0,5 prozent das könnte über
20 jahre gestreckt ungefähr 300
milliarden euro bringen also eine sehr
effektive maßnahme wir gehen zu ariane
müller in todesfelde bei bad segeberg im
norden frau müller hallo schön dass sie
da sind und was möchten sie gerne in die
diskussion einbringen hallo
vielen dank dass ich mit in die runde
kommen
meine frage ist eigentlich klar hin oder
auch im statement ich habe das im ob das
zu wenig ist was die rentner bekommen
und zwar für
energiepolitik ist das eben auch rentner
die viel geld bekommen diese 300 euro
bekommen sollen und die die ganz wenig
haben klingen auch einmalig 300 euro
ich habe das in meiner familie meiner
mutti kriegt eine sehr gute rente ist
damit sehr zufrieden und das ich brauche
das geld eigentlich gar nicht dafür und
aber die wirklich kleine renten bekommen
haben im prinzip nichts davon dass total
300 euro nicht so verpufft einfach so
und das ist ja eigentlich ja und das
ist ja auch so wenn man eine mutti immer
mehr geld bekommt an rente wird immer
hoch besteuert und muss dieses geld
wieder zurückzahlen wird besteuert mit
1700 euro hat diese im jahr die sie
zurückzahlen wollen start und sie meint
also ich brauche diese erhöhung gar
nicht das ist eigentlich ein unsinn ich
komme damit klar angekommen ich habe
ihre haare und verstanden ja also das
gießkannenprinzip bei den 300 euro ist
das eigentlich so gerecht und sinnvoll
also es gab ihre haltung in der runde
ich weiß nicht ich hatte noch nicht
bitte ich meine das ist das problem
immer wenn du eine pauschale leistung
auf die beine stellen schnell gehen
sollte und ich glaube an der steller die
bundesregierung
auf die kritik der letzten tage und
wochen reagiert und wollte eine schnelle
unkomplizierte variante habe aber es ist
genauso wie sie beschreiben auf der
anderen seite muss man sagen dort wo
dann wirklich sozusagen noch soziale not
darüber hinaus besteht dort greifen ja
auch andere instrumente noch die in
diesem papier enthalten sind also über
wohngeld und ähnlichem bei den rentnern
aber auch nun also rentner hat auch
wohngeldberechtigt ja sag ich ja also
unter greifen dann halt auch also wenn
wenn sozusagen diejenigen die dann so
wenig bekommen würden weil alle 300
bekommen gibt es halt auch noch andere
teile aus dem paket die dazu führen dass
es am ende auch dort geholfen werden
kann danke dann weiter zu britta bunke
wucherpfennig aus duderstadt
und ihre frage bitte hallo hallo ja ich
habe folgende frage mir jetzt auch
gestoßen das gesagt wurde dass studenten
oder studierende dafür ja immer aus
nicht haben auf einen guten job und dass
die ja diese 200 euro jetzt nicht
brauche und sagte ja hauptsächlich auch
aus gut verdienenden familien kämen also
ich kenne genug studenten auch aus
meiner familie bei denen das nicht so
ist und hier auch langzeit zusätzlich
sind teilweise und für wii kommt ja auch
die preiserhöhung ist supermarkt und
auch bei der mieterhöhung oder bei den
nebenkosten
die frage ich glaube ich habe ein
statement von frau siemens wiedererkannt
die möchte antworten frau lehmann aber
auch also ich finde daher gilt genau das
gleiche über renten an es gibt studenten
gerade eben wenn sie aus elternhäusern
kommen denen es nicht so gut geht also
in der regel kriegen die dann auch bafög
wenn sie nicht langzeitstudenten sind
weil das natürlich eben gerne an die
regelstudienzeit gebunden aber
da ist es auch so dass da 200 euro
wahrscheinlich nicht reichen werden weil
um diese härten abzufedern die reben
gerade auch lebensmittel betrifft
mobilität und so weiter wir haben das ja
gehört insofern bin ich stimme ich ihnen
zu also man sollte an am unteren ende
auch bei den studenten mehr geben was
aber auf alle fälle richtig ist es dass
derjenige der ein studium erfolgreich
absolviert sehr gute jobchancen hat den
deutsch pole mann ich wollte ihnen schon
in diesem punkt holen widersprechen frau
7 erstens ist es nicht so dass ganz
viele studierende aus gut verdienenden
familien kommen sondern wir kommen in
erster linie aus akademikerfamilien das
ist ein unterschied also akademiker ist
ja nicht gleich gut verdient es gibt
auch schlecht verdienende akademikerin
zwei sagen die auswertung des deutschen
studentenwerks regelmäßig da es über 60
prozent der studierenden arbeiten
nebenbei arbeiten um sich ihr studium
beziehungsweise die lebenshaltungskosten
leisten zu können und drittens finde es
bei den studierenden am ehesten noch
gerechtfertigt dass man da sofort hilfen
zahlt weil bei studierenden kann man ja
davon ausgehen dass sie am anfang ihres
berufslebens stehen und jetzt alle keine
gutverdiener sind und mit 18 ist man in
meinen augen auch sündiger mensch und er
sollte nicht immer das konto der eltern
als hintergrund für die eigene
bedürftigkeit herangezogen werden also
ausnahmsweise zwei einlassungen zu
dieser frage weil wir das eben auch
schon in der diskussion hatten ich
möchte gerne zu wolfgang rechtlos ski
gehen affalterbach in der nähe von
stuttgart
hallo und ihre frage bitte ja guten
tagen die runde mein name ist fritzl
sie sind dran harris gba kundentag in
die runde meine frage ist ganz einfach
der staat hat doch die überhöhten preise
erhebliche mehreinnahmen in mehreren co2
steuer man spricht von zehn milliarden
und wenn diese mehreinnahmen gleich als
abschlag bei der meisterfeier oder bei
der co2 speicher weitergegeben würde der
würfel durch schon bereits für sehr hohe
entlastung stattfinden ich habe die
frage verstanden danke für ihre
einlassung es geht darum die einnahmen
aus der co2 steuer baum können die nicht
direkt an die bürger zurückgegeben
werden in diesem zusammenhang übrigens
wurde die erhöhung der co2 steuer um ein
jahr geschoben sollte eigentlich zum
ersten januar wieder erhöht werden um
fünf euro pro tonne das ist jetzt
geschoben worden aber herr brücke hat
schon die ganze zeit gelegt weniger
eifrig und freue mich über die
einlassung er meinte ja wenn ich es
richtig verstanden sie nicht nur die co2
bedingten mehreinnahmen sondern die
inflationsbedingten mehr einnahmen die
der staat ja vor allem eine
mehrwertsteuer hat auch aus der mehrwert
auch aus der wäsche insofern ja völlig
zurecht und ich hoffe nicht dass die
also eigentlich müssten die 121
wiedergegeben werden weil das wäre eine
sinnvolle maßnahmen sind mich auch durch
den exogenen schock bedingte
mehreinnahmen die dem staat jetzt so
sonst nicht zugestanden hätten insofern
volle zustimmung über welchen kanal ist
dann wie zurückgegeben wird könnte
natürlich die kalte progression sein
muss man sehen aber ja volle zustimmung
also könnte die kalte progression sein
dass es so möchte ich hier aus führen
das ist das inflationsausgleichs gesetz
das vorsieht dass dadurch dass die
preise steigen man in eine andere
einkommen steuerklasse kommt und dann
mehr steuern zahlen muss das ist der von
christian lindner vorgelegte plan
sozusagen die grenzen dadurch anzuheben
hatte er schon im juli angekündigt und
soll jetzt auch so kommen könnte sich
gegebenenfalls in diesem zusammenhang
auftritten haben sie jetzt genau es sind
allerdings nur 12 bis 13 milliarden euro
was jetzt lindner vorschlägt und in
wahrheit sind die inflationsbedingten
mehr ein deutlich über halb von dem was
er mit der kalten progression an die
steuerzahler zurückgeben will danke man
kann ja gar nicht genug erklären bei
diesem thema wir schaffen bestimmt noch
eine frage nämlich klaus borchert in
hamburg main und gerne ihren beitrag zu
dieser diskussion
ich bin etwas wacklig und die kommen ja
noch auf einer vergangenen zeit wir
hatten hier die schläfe thw hein gas um
so was alles kommunale unternehmen die
zu einem wirklichen preis bei sehr guten
gehältern aber nicht so gut
vorstandsgehältern keine investoren
befriedigen mussten und keine
spekulanten aber für alle ein gutes
system geschaffen haben heute habe ich
das gefühl wir haben ein wegelagerer
systems an sie überall der hand
aufgehalten wird zum apportieren ich
behaupte immer folgendes mit dem
vergangenen system ist deutschland
merken krieg aufgebaut worden dass wir
mit diesem system mit sicherheit nicht
passiert irgendwann völlig aus dem ruder
gelaufen ja danke herr borchert in genau
frau siemens hat hier sofort reagiert
dass das aber natürlich eine andere
situation gewesen also ist liegt nicht
bei anderen dass wir jetzt private
unternehmen haben und da auch gewinne
gemacht werden dürfen dass der
energiemarkt zurzeit verrückt spielt
sondern dass wir den größten anbieter
europas sind beim gast der welt einfach
mal aus dem markt genommen haben und das
ist ein riesenteil deutschland ist davon
so abhängig wie sonst kaum ein land der
welt und
das müssen wir ersetzen
das heißt wir haben eine mangelsituation
dadurch und mangel ist auch immer eine
preis hat einmal preiseffekte also das
ist nicht die
verfahren eine frage des systems also
dass wir mit einem staatssystem besser
gefahren werden ich würde sogar sagen
wir wären mit einem staatssystem viel
schlechter gefahren ja danke frau 7 an
der stelle sind wir jetzt wirklich schon
im schlussspurt deshalb kann ich leider
keine weiteren fragen annehmen auch wenn
es noch viele gibt auch in den sozialen
medien wurde noch durchaus heftig
diskutiert ich freue mich sehr dass wir
erster einordnung in dieser runde hier
vornehmen konnten das ist ja jetzt quasi
gerade mal zwei stunden alt das dritte
entlastungs paket mit allen seinen
details und ich bin mir sicher dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen das auch noch
in den stunden und tagen weiter
beobachten werden wir sicherlich hier im
presseclub auch noch das thema energie
preise inflation überhaupt der krieg in
der ukraine und wie halten wir zusammen
und kommen durch diesen herbst und
winter war sicherlich nicht das letzte
mal dass wir hier diskutiert haben
vielen dank für ihr interesse ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen sonntag
alles gute
[Musik]